border crossing searched 23 percent in
March nearly 200
000 people uh crossing a border uh
migrant encounters at the U.S Mexico
border increased by 23 in March compared
to February with a total of 191 900
Rivals counted by the U.S Customs and
Border Protection the agency stressed
that the March Figures were down
compared to march of the previous year
and that the majority six to nine
percent of the encounters were single
adults acting CBP commissioner Troy
Miller noted that the agency continues
to work around the clock to maintain
border security they emphasize that the
increase in immigrant and migrant
encounters between February and March is
typically as winter temperatures rise
and a 23 increase was significantly less
than the 34 surge of the same month last
year this by the way how big of an issue
Tom will this be for 2024 elections this
is going to be huge because you know
what's not being covered is the the
crime that uh Arizona and uh New Mexico
and Texas are facing if you take a look
and by the way Greg Abbott
um regardless of what you feel about
Texas regardless of you about Greg
Abbott he has been very accurately
describing the statistics of crime that
are happening in the border cities with
all of these folks coming over looking
for looking for the jobs looking for a
place or they're coming over here
because they're on a mission because
they're part of a drug cartel and
they're and they're part of a
distribution expansion and so this is
going to be a huge issue in Arizona and
New Mexico and you're seeing it you're
seeing it pat in things moving because
Kerry Lake was just part of it Kerry
lake is not Kerry Lake without part of
the immigration issue that was creating
problems not not the racist
anti-immigration because we all came
from somewhere my folks are from Canada
your folks from some point were from
Israel I mean look look where you from
Iran you know you wherever you were from
from New York
you know it's like whoever this guy's
from no but we're all here from someone
give us your tired report we all come
from somewhere but the problems that
were happening in Arizona that led to
the emergence Kerry Lake and so you take
a look at this is still a huge huge
issue and by the way these folks need
housing so to all of the people in
Hollywood Music Industry kept
threatening to move to Canada will you
please go we need room yeah exactly
imagine let's not let's not lie to
ourselves these are like we talked about
it before these are all votes for
Democrats because I don't know if you
watched mayorkas has been on on like the
judicial house and all these hearings
where they're like the Republicans are
grilling in they keep telling them about
all these numbers all all these kids
that are coming over Pat they're making
these 15 year old kids work and he's
like what about the labor laws and and
no answers no straight answer he always
floats around it it's a crisis like look
at dude 23 surge in marched 100 and they
want these people here what about all
the kids they're actually having kids
work all these kids that are
disappearing that are coming over the
Border because they're unaccompanied uh
children has skyrocketed and it's like
the left doesn't care all they have to
say is oh no we look we love them we
care they don't give a damn bro those
are going to be votes trust me those are
votes for the Democratic party because
they're going to remember those people
who let them in because you know what
they're going to say the Republicans
said no no but remember Democrats they
wanted you to come in here so did you
see the exchange uh between Holly and
Alejandro mayorkas I love see that or no
let me send this to you Rob I'm gonna
I'm gonna text it to you if you can pull
this up it's a very interesting exchange
that these guys have uh obviously he
gets pushed pretty hardcore uh let me
see if this is the one
yeah I think this may be the one and he
never answers one question right he
never answers one one straight answer
ever he's my Yorkers he's he's just a he
has that smirk on his face because he
knows what's going on bro he was put
there to just let everybody come in wait
one second when I'm placenting to you
not that one play this one I'm about to
send to you today Holly's and Holly's a
pretty you know he he's a gangster he
loves him back down I just sent you the
second one play the second one from
C-SPAN he's OG on what these guys are
doing it's just kind of like well you
know uh look you know you are misstating
the facts so terribly you know yeah it's
um a sense of casualness with the issue
that's going on at the border but I do
believe this is also going to be another
one of those top five issues that will
be brought up in the election in 2024.
can make that bigger and
yeah this guy he doesn't play games
Holly goes afterwards again as shelters
filled with children
the administration began loosening
vetting restrictions and urging case
managers to speed the process along
you have at every stage facilitated
modern day indentured servitude of minor
children yep why should you not be
impeached for this
I look forward to discussing this issue
further because you are
misstating the facts uh so uh terribly I
am reading you the facts from articles
in the news and your usual modus
operandi is what you're doing again
today was just to deny deny deny why
have you permitted 345
000 children to come into this country
unaccompanied why have you permitted
thousands of them to be abused and
exploited yep Senator what we do is we
enforce the law but let me just say this
look where and when yeah no answer not
one Pad
but guys
these in full length he doesn't answer
one question the Republicans the only
ones holding his foot to the fire you
know what the Democrats are saying when
they ask them questions they're like so
you know you're letting these people
you're helping these people what's your
favorite video game like stuff like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah like it's like it's
insane and again these are gonna be one
of those points where when it comes to
voting time people are going to say
listen look at the border look how many
are coming over look at the search but
dude by that time it might be it might
be too late so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign